my next guest grew up in a catholic
family father was kind of agnostic ended
up doing the new age thing consciousness
meditation third eye astrology crystals
kind of like this but this and like put
it under your pillow because it almost
like helps you come into like a
spiritual awakening okay so that's
really cool it just gives off really
good energy this apparently has um
interaction with like your third eye i
don't know if you know about that some
spiritual stuff and then he met a
christian woman started going deeper
into christianity after he got baptized
but
he started having more questions and
answers he wanted something clear
precise without contradiction he wasn't
getting it he became an agnostic but he
was still doing some good things he was
pushing the nofap
helping people with addictions and
dealing with addictions became a youtube
star
and let's see where he's at in life
today with andrea my special guest
how are you doing brother
did you get your cold shower in today
no i haven't i haven't yet but
absolutely you're still doing the cold
showers
every now and then periodically
now that you say that i'ma have to hop
back on them every single day all right
how did it
so tell us let's start off uh people can
see your story in detail you have it out
there it's on your channel i want to
kind of touch upon it
but i want to go into this let's tell us
what's this because this is kind of like
a growing movement let's let's watch
this again and you can give us some
details let me talk about the third eye
these crystal spirituality sleep with
this and like put it under your pillow
because it almost like helps you come
into like a spiritual awakening okay so
that's really cool it just gives off
really good energy this apparently has
um interaction with like your third eye
i don't know if you know about that some
spiritual stuff
what the is that third eye what's going
on it's like the jowl what are they
talking about yes
it's a lot so
the whole
new age stuff has its roots in
hinduism
a lot of people don't realize that but
it has its roots in hinduism and in
hinduism you have these things known as
the chakras and the third eye is uh the
the second to final chakra before the
crown chakra
it's all it's pretty ridiculous and i
don't want to like throw dirt on
them you know like we're even told not
to
speak uh badly
over another person's religion or
something like that
but when you start getting into this
stuff you you start to see how
kind of uh
twisted it all is how altered it all
is and then you have this kind of what's
this like so getting into meditation
no problem i mean we try to we can
contrast that with like you know islam
we try to meditate you know i mean
really getting into salah you know
connecting with the one creator
right being grateful for all the
blessings etc so when you talk about
meditation what kind of meditation are
you talking about at that time that
you're doing what does it entail and
this consciousness we i think
consciousness you think about taqwa
consciousness of yeah that's what it
should be yeah that's what it should be
what did it translate for you then
um then
the whole consciousness aspect was more
so like
um they said you open up your pineal
blend and when you open up your
financial and it's like you're opening
yourself up to a different dimension
keep this in mind a different dimension
now people do
all these different
techniques to go into this different
dimension
um
this different dimension they call it
the astral rung
i think it's
you probably referred to as like maybe
the fifth dimension or something like
that
but when you go into this place and when
your experience is like you kind of open
yourself up to things where
some might be good but
they are going to be bad as well and
after coming to the song you kind of
start to realize okay
these things that i was experiencing
then this
this state and all this stuff like that
this is gins
this is jin's this is no
if ands of butts but it is what you're
watching
what's gins
when you do these techniques to open up
your third eye you actually open
yourself up to gins
yeah
yeah so people actually take this uh
when you do when you do what when you do
this uh third eye stuff yeah yeah so
they have um they have like
transcendental meditation they have um
this one yoga called the shambhali
mahamudra
they have actual projection
certain practices they have even drugs
like
dmt you can literally smoke the the dmt
in and of itself
and what these things do
is uh it takes you somewhere else it
makes you experience more than what you
are experiencing here
and the things that you experience
wherever you go
listen like after coming to islam i know
that that's that's jin's there's no way
fans are but cause you've experienced it
you know what it entails unfortunately
you have some even some muslims naively
like jumping into this kind of stuff
and experimenting but this is clear so
you from your experience from what
you've you're actually you're entering
into this unseen realm of the evil
spirit the jinns yeah
what about these crystals we hear about
these crystals
see i never really like understood the
crystals too much because
um if you look at quartz crystal
they use that in watches
yeah and it's a
it's i think it's called um pi piezo
electric or pyroelectric i might be
butchering that term
but um the crystal in and of itself
is
capable of conducing electricity so they
use it in the watch therefore to
basically power the watch
now as far as like okay
us theorizing that like okay well if
this crystal can do that then that music
can do all these other things and each
crystal has its own little property
that's that's kind of questionable and
when i was getting into it you know i
didn't really fully
accept the whole crystals like oh this
crystal makes you more clear cognitively
and stuff like that
but um
[Music]
there was one crystal in particular that
was i think it was called um
[Music]
i gotta get back to you on the name but
it was like a greenish type stone
crystal and i never understood why but
anytime that i would
keep this
this stone like next to me i would start
feeling really out of it like
my mind would just be all foggy and
i i just i couldn't think properly and i
know i know this is true because every
time that i i had that next to me same
experience every single time
jins again
perhaps you you get into experiment this
stuff this is all stuff shaytan is like
having the tools that he's using to like
mislead people and get you distracted
over here when you should be directing
all your attention to the one who
created you that's crazy
yeah so let's go back to the other one
so there's a lot of drugs involved in
opening up with the subconscious we've
seen like
some um people going to mexico some
celebrities
and then they there's a special drug
that they get from the lizard
no no no if it's if it's from the lizard
it's some animal it can be something
else if it's if it's an animal i think
it's called toad toad that's the one
that's the toad yeah
oh it's the same it's um
i think i think they referred to as um
m-a-o-i
uh-huh so what the same thing takes you
into that different realm what is that
yeah yeah it's
you could call it like a psychedelic
psychedelic you could call it like a
psychedelic but the realm that you're
entering
is not hallucinogenic like yeah
there's something more happening there
because like the things that people
experience
is very similar
you know and then like you
you encounter different beings different
entities
there and like these people that are
doing these things they don't know what
it is so
they're doing it and then they're
thinking oh i'm encountering this being
this entity this entity's helping me and
all that stuff but like little do you
know
that this right here is a jin
because there's been many reports where
people go into these uh
these states
right
and then they start to interact with
these entities and these entities they
come off
at first they come off nice they come
off uh
non-threatening like helping them
and then like after
after they've been
with this entity for x amount of time
like then they do a switch up and
the entity turns into just this like
this evil thing that's
completely out to
ruin this person's experience at that
time so
yeah it's it's uh
it's crazy
you got a lot of experience i most
people like who tasted all this stuff
and then you come to what we'll talk
about later the way apart life you're
apart now it's like
uh night and day huh what about
astrology now also
uh
i
i never dipped too far into that
but i i have had experiences
where
i talk to people who are quote unquote
uh i guess you could say astrologers i'm
not strawberries
they don't even refer to themselves as
that they um
the tarot card readers
who use astrology and then they use all
this stuff to be able to like
tell people's fortunes and all this
stuff and and some of the things i saw
were pretty scary how accurate they were
but
again coming to islam you start to
understand like how it all works how the
gin are just
wow yeah
back to the gin right
you know the the um hadith that talks
about you know about the jinn just
paraphrasing it and then they'll end up
getting some information and it'll be
one truth mixed with 99 lies right kind
of reminds me of uh when people bring up
like nostradamus
nostradamus
and then he'll like kind of have some
vague statements that he made and people
cling to that but then they forget about
like all the hundreds of things that he
guessed that are just wrong you know
blatantly wrong and then something that
possibly can fit but you have like these
people you're talking about who
uh hook up with the unseen world of the
jinn right
yeah yeah so islam has those answers it
tells you there's that unseen world and
so a lot of these things you can
pinpoint back to the gin
yeah
it's crazy oh it's crazy the more you
get into it the more you get into islam
like the more everything else makes
sense
you know because it's like everything
else only has like
in my understanding from when i was
studying different you know
religions different experiences and
stuff like that is that
it's
they all have like little pieces of the
the puzzle but when you get into islam
like there's there's all the pieces all
the pieces are there so again like the
more you get to islam the more you
understand
then you went and you almost got married
right you were engaged to a christian
woman you got you went real deep then
and you took a deep dive you got
baptized
what happened from there
uh so i tried getting into the whole
christianity thing um
it it had its it had its points you know
like there was definitely that um
community type vibe
whenever you go to the churches but
don't ask any questions
i forbid you ask any questions that i
would ruin the whole community type vibe
what else
uh i i tried to vibe with the notion
that that jesus was
god but it just it never
it never sat well and like any time i
would even have that thought like run
across my mind i'm just like
it just it doesn't make sense it doesn't
connect like this there's something
wrong here
so and that just kind of led me like
after her in my split it led me to
just kind of stray away from the whole
christianity concept because it's again
it doesn't make sense and then you can't
ask questions because
god forbid it you know
did you ever go back to her does she
know that she ended up accepting islam
did you ever go talk to her again and
what was her reaction
to you i have no idea you guys lost
touch yeah we lost touch i think the
last time we talked was um
definitely probably like
seven or eight months before i became
muslim
so i don't know if she knows maybe she
does maybe he doesn't
yeah subhanallah
so uh you you make an example it's like
ikea
you know when if you get something
an instruction manual you want it to be
clear and precise and it seems like with
all these other ways that were out there
you weren't getting what was clear and
precise you were getting all these
things left on interpretation
oh yeah
yeah it was um
i think with everything
with everything that i was getting into
it there was never a clear like okay
this is it this is what you do this is
how you do it here you have questions go
ahead ask your questions but all the
answers are here for you
i never had that and then
again like when i came onto islam
before i even saw those answers it all
clicked for me so finalized like a lot
was just kind of like confirming like
hey
before you even have any questions
let me let you know that this is the
truth
so that way you can already be primed
and ready for
this i think you'd make a good candidate
to be on the joe rogan podcast
you saw a lot man yeah
i mean i think you'd i think you got a
lot i got a lot in common i think most
uh
of the things that some of the things he
talks about you guys actually had him
you guys uh you and the brothers that
you had you were commenting on one of
his uh programs it seemed like he did
kind of a turn where he was talk since
we mentioned the word islam he started
mentioning the word islam he was talking
about it in a positive light let's go
into this next video where you and the
brothers the three muslims you're
actually kind of uh you know talking
about one of his programs
islam originally was the
scientists man i mean they were they if
you look at this the early islamic world
they were the ones that
were the most advanced at one point in
history they were the ones that were
pushing mathematics and science and and
reason and logic you know it's just it
comes in cycles man it comes in cycles
of suppression and dominance and
you know the the real concern is
unstoppable dictatorships like china and
russia and when when there's no dissent
and no discussion i've got a lot of
friends who are arabs i've spent a lot
of time in the middle east
i love them they're awesome there are
some
that's deep i love them they're awesome
it takes like that was one of the
misconceptions you had when he said arab
you thought all arabs all muslims were
arabs is that right yeah
yeah
yeah
so what were you guys discussing there
it was fascinating to see joe because
we've done some programs before where he
kind of like got out of his lane and we
respectfully kindly academically we
brought on some scholars we addressed
the issues that he was talking about
because he had he had some guests
that were spewing this hate rhetoric
misinformation
and
then we
academically cleared it up and it just
nice to see him actually talking about
islam and this where you got in this
video in a positive light
what was your guys conclusion at the end
what were you guys some of the things
that you guys
discussed in that video um if i remember
100
but i think he was um
i think the thing that he was referring
to was that
uh maybe maybe islam has the answers
or maybe i'm i'm getting it wrong that
that's deep i think the the title was uh
is joe rogan secretly a muslim
yeah yeah yeah so okay i'm not wrong
yeah i'm not wrong he was uh he was
saying that like maybe
maybe islam has the answers maybe the
muslims have the answers here that's
like the whole gist of like what we were
trying to get at what he was trying to
get at
yeah so
now because he takes to a kind of person
that you think he's experienced he does
a lot of those psychedelics right the
marijuana he does a lot of the uh
different drugs he's he's open to
experimenting right so why not
experiment with islam you've
experimented with everything else yeah
what do you think that's the next step
for him
right
yeah
i think any anyone my bad for cutting
off but anyone who does psychedelics
like the next step for them is islam
because once you once you've had these
experiences like i myself you know stuff
for allah that i had these experiences
in my jahilia but
i feel like when i came to islam those
experiences
were just kind of cemented and
allah just kind of made it like okay
look those experiences you had
this is why that happened
this is why there was this this is why
you you ran into this is why this system
this you know what i'm saying so it's
like for anyone who has done
psychedelics like islam is the next step
what would you tell joe rogan
what would you if you had a chance
what would you say to joe our friend joe
i don't think i'm the best person to
speak to him i think probably mohammed
hijab might be the best person to speak
why not i mean you're you have a lot in
common i mean a lot of the things i'm
sure that he's been through a lot of
things you know you're you're a person
that strikes me as someone if something
is good you know you're open you know
you're quick to make your discipline
willpower you help people you know with
any of these addictions and whatnot you
got a lot of positive character traits
alhamdulillah and you know we can't just
throw the baby out with the bad father
you know joe rogan also he talks about
some good things also and i think that
you would you would have a lot of things
in common it'd be a good conversation
so now if you had that conversation if
it happened
you say hey joe what's up you know what
would you tell him hey joe
uh first off i'd tell him
[Music]
like what does he think about islam
you know and see what his thoughts are
like see where he's at in that that
journey and then from there i didn't
bite him
uh not to
you know 100 accept islam from the rip
but i'd invite him to
take on a dopamine detox
kind of strip everything away and then
try out the ramadan fasting for a few
days now we're talking there you go yeah
so in the ramadan fashion you understand
okay we're getting
joe rogan now you're giving this his
sincere advice one human to another
dopamine detox you were doing these
what's the dopamine detox it's very
simple you you strip everything away
you make life as simple as possible the
way that the creator intended
right so you spend time in nature spend
time with the people that you love
and just spend less if
zero time on electronics yeah so no
entertainment
um
no books even i'd say
in in that little specific time right so
if he's gonna do that i'd say try this
out man like three four days
strip everything away
and then also from sunrise to sunset
don't drink any water don't eat any food
and just spend time outside spend time
meditation to spend time self-reflecting
he goes hunting
yeah yeah yeah so i'm sure he's he's had
like
very close states to what i'm referring
to
maybe not in the dry fast state
that's the big changer here
is if he were to add the dopamine detox
into
a dry fasted state which is the whole
ramadan fasting type deal and i feel
like from there
from there like he would probably start
to
you know connect the dots insha'allah
and then you can talk to him about look
that experience your experience before
and then you talk about these waves look
these waves we know that look islam is
based on
proof
evidence right for the person who wants
scientific proof you know he wants to
look at the quran unchanged tamper-free
temper proof if he wants to look at all
of the things the prophecies you know
there's no way that this human being
that prophet muhammad peace and muslim
upon them could have came up with all
these things but then you have your
personal experiences also you know that
i'm sure someone he'd be like man i want
to feel that we know that people unless
they're really truly connected with
their creator there's always that void
there's that void you know
and then talk about this this these
waves you know that we're going this
feeling now you know once you start to
come to you know you said you read the
quran three times was that right yeah
yeah talk about that
and these waves what are you talking
about these waves
uh so the waves happened the first time
the waves happened um the third day of
reading the quran
each time i would read the quran i would
you know kind of reflect sit and reflect
in like a meditation afterwards
and the third day of reading the quran i
wasn't muslim at the time but everything
just kind of clicked
and
when everything clicked it's like
something inside me was like yeah
yeah i guess i guess allah is
the only god
i guess i i guess the prophet sallallahu
alaikum is
the final messenger and like when all
that clicked when it clicked and my mind
just kind of went blame for a second
like all these waves just started going
in and out of my body
very difficult to explain but that's the
best explanation i have for it and
when that happened i was like oh yeah
i'm definitely a muslim
so you were you were dealing with like
what most people you were dealing with
would you say classified like a deep
depression
you know what had you because you went
through so many different phases in life
uh
if you go back catholic family father
agnostic
and then you have the going deep into
christianity before that all of these
different uh
you know the new age movement and then
kind of back to what your father was
upon agnosticism until finally you kind
of left islam towards was it towards the
end why was that you had these
preconceived notions also that islam was
oppressive and whatnot why was it left
at the end
yeah so
um first off i i'd like to think that i
don't have uh
deep depression you know i guess
everyone would like to think that they
don't have any
psychological issues or any trauma or
anything like that but
i've been through a rough life man and i
noticed that any time that
i would get like by myself
and i would kind of strip everything
away
and i didn't have any distractions and
none other so it would always lead to
being in that depressive state you know
i've said it multiple times so i'm not
ashamed of saying it um
i was abused i was abused around my
childhood my parents were divorced early
on
and and the list goes on and on and on
so it's like i guess yeah i guess i do
struggle with some deep depression and
uh
aside from that why did i leave islam to
the end
i think i left islam towards the end
because
the the people that i had met who were
muslim
they uh
their character
showed so much like so much i guess hope
you could say you know because it
uh when you see a muslim who's like
really on dean like
you know this
you can feel this you don't have to be
muslim in order to
experience
someone else's character
right and the the people who i had run
into who were muslim who had that
that thakua who had that that character
that oclock and the manners and all that
man
i was just like yo like kind of like how
joe rogan seemed like maybe maybe islam
is it but for some reason you know i
like
i don't know i i just didn't
it was kind of like a resistance
internal internally i guess you could
say
would that be the resistance to like
okay what he she's gonna say my parents
what society you think what you falling
into that category because that happens
a lot doesn't it
yeah i'd say two categories can that
category that you just said because you
know this negative stigma over here in
the west you've got islam being
portrayed as a terrorist religion
and um
yeah it's just nothing but bad
connotation
bad things that are associated with it
here in the west at least you know
and the other
side is like
people want to know the truth
but people are afraid of knowing the
truth
because once you know the truth like you
can't go back
you know like you you're in a state of
ignorance
once you take the red pill you you can't
go back to sleep you can't go back into
the dream you know what i'm saying
so like once you realize islam is the
truth
good luck going back
i survived
you said you said a word also that we'll
touch upon hopefully i won't forget red
pill
you mentioned when you take the red pill
that's from the uh matrix right that
will be the matrix and then they're
offered the blue and the red and then
what does that signify
that red pill when he took the red pill
was it keanu reeves
what does that signify when he took the
red pill when he took the reptil in the
movie
he was uh waking up from the matrix and
the matrix was this uh
false programming this false reality so
it's like
what he was living
and what everyone else was living it was
all fake it was all like this program
that was just being
run on and run on but when you took the
red pill you step out of that program
and then you start to see like what life
really was and that's that's kind of
like what happens when
you get into islam did you become a pua
at one point
that's the
the guys that go around hating on girls
right
is it p p u a pickup artist yeah pick up
artists yeah i
unfortunately yeah i did
at one point i mean that's before islam
everything is like a goal right it's
just like you know if you're in that
world of like there's nothing to measure
morality by
why not like where would we
where would you be without why why
should you not do such and such and such
right
yeah it's like that that uh
verse goes like do you not see
the one who takes his uh
his desires as his
his lord
and that's exactly what it is
subhanallah
and this is what men i mean it's in the
quran
it's like the one thing that men desire
the most is
it's allah is telling us it's in the
cross so now if you don't have no
perimeters you don't have no guidelines
no rules to live by
then
you become a pickup artist
and if you have the ability it's crazy
huh because that's a lot of times
associated with with this uh red pill
right
yeah we'll get into that later let's go
back to this depression now i want to
make this clear because it's not just
because okay now
because in the beginning you accept
islam and it's kind of like you know
the hadith where the prophet saw some
last final message talks about like when
someone enters islam submission to the
will of the creator not the creation is
like he's like a newborn baby all his
sins
just you know are wiped away
and you have that feeling like that did
you experience that feeling in the
beginning like
yeah you know what i'm talking about you
just like on cloud nine you're just
you're feeling just amazing yeah yeah
additionally
there's no such thing as a cloud night
but i'm just like yeah yeah you know
metaphorically 100 yeah
um i've felt it and i'd say like i still
feel it
but i'd say
now that i'm like closing in on a year
maybe a little bit more actually you
know we we still haven't had a year yet
me being muslim
but as i'm closing in on this year it's
like
i'm kind of still seeing like okay
i still did what i did you know allah
forgave me for it a lot
put like a blanket over it
but i'm still like
i still did it
nonetheless like i still had that
experience and the the the sad part is
is like a mind stretched by a new
experience can never go back to its old
dimensions
so it's like i've already done those
things there's no way that i can just
eliminate that from my life from my mind
so it's still there so yeah i still feel
like that cloud9 type feeling but then
it's like i'm still remembered like yeah
i still did that
you know so it i'd say it humbles me and
instead of me being on cloud9 it's more
like okay i'm just i'm just kind of like
sober
i'm sober yeah
so a couple points one thing is
obviously we're not proud of our past
and we don't
want to go into any of the details but
it just kind of because people are
chasing that lifestyle so now you can
say hold on hold on i went that way you
don't want to go that direction i was
there i did all those things that you're
doing now and you're going to hit a dead
end i hit the dead end
why are you going to go hit a dead end
or the bridge is out you're going to
fall down the mountain why are you going
to do that i've been there you don't
have to do it you can experience it
through my my lens my life i mean so
that's the thing
that we try to get out like people
who've been there and done that look at
their lives now look how unhappy they
were and look where they're they're at
now and the other point was about the
depression
uh i don't want people to think like um
you know you find the purpose of life
obviously now you have that contentment
that peace and tranquility but you can't
fall into all of us do myself included
we all fall into those times of
struggles and and you can get depressed
right but you have the tools to get you
out of that you have zikr right you have
allah it's like a beautiful example is
like you're on the ocean
they're not yet muslim non-muslim the
muslim they're going to both let's say
be on an on the ocean and then those
waves are hitting the turbulence is
hitting whatever one has allah one
doesn't
right yeah
yeah so at the end now you have the
tools you get through it inshallah and
you're stronger so
have you seen that has you how was that
when you would hit certain times in your
life and you didn't have these tools
that you're learning about you're
getting more and more grounded in the
dean
how is that helping you to navigate
through life as opposed to before
when it was the other the new age stuff
and all these other things that were at
your disposal yeah so it's like you said
bro
it's like you said where it's like now
you have
this guidebook now you have these
guidelines now you know what to do
so it doesn't mean that you are
accept doesn't mean that you will never
feel depressed
or you'll never experience hardship it's
just now you know what to do when you
experience the hardship versus before
i wasn't muslim when i didn't have the
guidelines when i didn't have the
guidebook i didn't know what i was doing
so anytime
i would be feeling like life is amazing
i would become very arrogant i'll become
very boastful and be like ah like
it's because of me like i'm the one
doing this here right and then
a lot of like okay say list you know
like you think this is all you think
this is all you let's see and then he
strips it away
and then when he strips all the way like
the sub swing that i'll go through
because
i didn't have any guidelines i didn't
know what to do so i'm over here
trying to do the best that i can to get
past it so
for for someone who's not on dean that
might look
like them maybe partaking in drugs more
maybe drinking alcohol more maybe
spending way too much time with other
people
maybe they are playing video games maybe
they're watching pornography maybe
they're doing something to kind of drown
themselves out from that depression that
they're experiencing but
people realize at some point or another
the only way out is through
like if you want to get through
depression if you want to get out of
depression you have to go through it
right if you are angry how do you stop
being angry you have to go through it
you have to let it run its course
if you uh let's say you hurt yourself
and you have to heal up like okay how do
you heal up it doesn't happen like that
you have to go through it so with all
these things like you're gonna have to
go through it so why not have something
that's like
here do this
do that
um living this style think in this way
this is gonna allow you to get past
what you're feeling here in the most
easiest way possible
you know what i'm saying
absolutely and this is what you want and
you continue to do helping people deal
with different addictions
and you have this video you can explain
what this nofap means did you you made
this before islam let's get into this
and you can kind of give us a breakdown
because this is a big addiction people
are dealing with pornography and all
these other dishes that changed my life
now if you don't know what nofap is it's
basically this movement that was created
where people stopped playing with
themselves and they stopped watching
pornography
i know
crazy right like
why would anyone
want to stop doing these things
but
i came across this
a few years back
and it's because i realized
that i had a problem i realized that hey
maybe what i'm doing isn't the best
thing
for people that have never heard this
nofap this is something new also to me
no is it no fap
no fact
yeah so for the next generation older
generation you know many people are not
keen to these new terms like what was
his message that you were getting out
there
yeah so
first of all let me just
say the the shirt that i had on in the
video i think was by far the most
comfortable shirt that
i've ever had in my life
but um no fat to get on top to get no
fat
um
nofap is basically where you stop
masturbating
you stop watching pornography
and for
this generation or at least
for the people who are outside of
religion
that's that's a big thing for them
you know like
it's free you can go on
the computer
your phone and you have access to
unlimited
things that will uh quote-unquote
fulfill your desire
all right but that's not the the best
thing in this world and the whole nofap
movement
it's basically to
eliminate these things so that your body
can kind of uh
go back to its normal state you see
because if someone watches pornography
what ends up happening is that it's
releasing an excessive amount of
dopamine into your system dopamine is a
neurotransmitter
kind of like uh
acetylcholine
serotonin
things along that ah all right there are
more for sure there are more official
i'm just not recalling them right now
but when you watch pornography it's
releasing this excessive amount of
dopamine
and
it's excessive because you would never
have this in nature it's not natural
for you to
be able to be with
let's say 40 50 60 different
sexual partners
within like
what 20 minutes 30 minutes
it's not possible like it's not
something that that allah made for us
a lot didn't create our bodies this way
right so what ends up happening is that
you have this excessive amount of
dopamine and then it basically
desensitizes your body to where
you become
less sensitive to real life
so let's say you walk outside and let's
say there's a butterfly that flies
across like
if you were sensitive you would look at
that butterfly and it would there would
be an impact because you'd be present
you would experience that fully but when
you are desensitized
it's like that butterfly flies across
and there's this lag time there's this
period where it's like you didn't really
experience it you just
you're kind of running like two to five
seconds behind the time frame that you
should be
you know so
to keep it more simple
um you're desensitized you're not going
to notice a butterfly if you're
sensitized you go outside and you see
that butterfly and you say supine
and um that's that's no fat that's all
it's doing it's just re-sensitizing your
body
and were you muslim at the time when you
made this
no i was not muslim
okay so you're actually putting it
pushing this positive message even
before islam
yeah so this is a movement of not yet
muslims non-muslims who started this
it's non-muslims for sure and if you get
like deep down to the bone nofap is is
actually a business unfortunately
yeah but still like it's still helping
people so yeah
so it is what it is in that sense
but um
nofap is meant to help people break free
from
destructive habits and addictions but
little do they know
that when they break free from these
things they actually get closer to their
creator they get more spiritual everyone
who's been on nofap will attest to the
same thing
this is deep uh so what do you think
from your experience dealing and talking
with this i had a guest on imam john he
makes the connection
he's lectured
uh helped a lot of the youth
people who are saying supposedly coming
out and saying look you know they're
having doubts about islam they're having
a faith iman crisis he connects this
crisis
much of it a great majority of it to
pornography addiction
because now you made the thing the
statement now that you end up getting
closer to your creator when you start
disconnecting here now reverse that
right you keep doing it what's the
opposite going to happen you're going to
get more distant
right so he so we did a program here and
we actually
uh
you have i think is one of the serial
killers on there
uh he was they were talking about fbi
and whatnot they were talking about i
forgot what the uh person's name was
one of them yeah it was a bundy and he
talks about how
you know this violent form of
pornography how this actually aided you
know them you know with their thinking
to go ahead and commit a lot of these
crimes what are your thoughts on that
it's it's the truth
it's the truth
because um when you watch these things
it's
it's programming you subconsciously
like i've i've talked to many people
who
they say that
you know what they learned in
pornography when they're having sex with
their
with their woman it's not the same and
i'm like well of course it's not the
same like what did you expect like
number one pornography is fake
they are literally acting
and they're recording the people people
behind cameras recording this
and then on top of that like everything
is done excessively
to appeal to people because what ends up
happening is
people when they start watching
pornography or they start taking drugs
they have this thing known as the
coolidge effect meaning that you need
more of the said thing in order to
experience the same feeling you felt in
the beginning so if someone drinks
alcohol
they're going to need more alcohol they
develop a tolerance right it's a simple
terminology a tolerance
someone smokes weed
the first time
there will never be another time like
the first time and every time that they
smoke weed after that they're gonna try
to
emulate and have that same experience as
the first time but they will never
experience that again
right so that's the coolidge effect now
pornography is the same thing you watch
pornography the more someone watches
pornography
the nastier the stuff they get into
until they're doing something that's
completely against
what they are like
they they could be a straight
heterosexual male and he could be so far
gone into pornography that he's now
watching homosexual
pornography but he's not he's not gay
himself but he's watching this because
he's literally desensitized himself so
much that now he needs that in order for
him
to
[Music]
get aroused and feel anything
so just think like if that's happening
with that like think about the other
stuff
that's occurring
and that's why it made sense to me what
he was saying this imam john what he was
saying
was that because of this this is leading
to a crisis of faith of iman with a lot
of people who are in this addiction
so what do you like to tell people who
are going through this addiction right
now they're they're tuning in where do
you like to start
how do you like to help people because
this is one of the things you do right
you help people dealing with these
different addictions
so having gone through a lot of these
things what would you tell the person
like where to start
how to
[Music]
get help are we for referring to
someone who is religious or are we
referring to someone who's secular
uh both
both okay so well it's gonna look
different for each one because obviously
each one has different beliefs and you
know different desires and stuff like
that
um but for the non-secular person i
always tell them like
what does the best version of yourself
look like
like i'm talking about like when you
watch a movie and you see like the
that character that's like the
the top character where you're just like
dang like that's that's pretty dope you
know like he's masculine
he's strong he's confident
he's uh he's stoic and all this stuff
all the stuff that they you might
attribute to this character
now look at yourself
i look at yourself as the main character
in your own life in your own movie
now what would this character be doing
would he be watching pornography all the
time
would he be masturbating all the time
the answer is probably not
and that's like that that makes a big
shift in people who are uh secular
now for people who are religious
it's really like it's all about
understanding like what they're doing
you know like
number one do you understand that time
is running out
number two do you understand that uh
we're not guaranteed
the next hour we're not guaranteed the
next minutes
nothing is guaranteed the only thing
that's guaranteed is that
we're going to die and we're going to be
gathered
right in front of our creator a day of
judgment
that's guaranteed
now if you are
religious you understand these two
things
and then you see what you're doing well
now it's a matter of like kind of
breaking it down okay why am i
going in this path why am i doing these
things and
a big one could be oh well i don't have
a spouse i'm not married you know and
and i'll i'll catch on to the i'll talk
on the ones where if they marry what
would they do
but um
nine times out of ten the
people who are doing this they're not
gonna be maybe right so they're trying
to fulfill their sexual urges
without actually going out here and
having sex with a woman without
performing zinna outside of marriage you
know but that
i don't know which one's worse man
i don't know which one's worse to watch
pornography or to actually go out there
and perform similar both of them are
terrible and the law has already said
this but it's like in reality like when
you look at like what's happening deep
down
on a uh
i guess
the the neurotransmitter level and all
that stuff like even on the spiritual
level like which one is actually worse
which one is worse here and they think
that watching pornography is worse when
like
it's not any better it's not any better
yeah and some people just that's how
shaytan plays that game he tries to ju
you try to you know make justifications
and now you even have now it's it's
instead of the vh tapes vhs tapes right
you have access all over but now you
actually you can dial up people end up
dialing up and you got someone live
oh yeah the live shows and all that
right it's getting it's getting
disgusting and it's getting to the point
where they're having 3d
the the virtual reality stuff
once it gets like deeper into that like
trust that
people are really gonna be
in a rough point but getting back to
what we were saying about like the guy
if if the guy realizes
that he's doing it because he's not
married well then the next question is
like okay well what's what's preventing
him from being married
and then
starting to do the work
necessary in order to
become married
so that way
you can get over the addiction because
the thing is with addictions is um
if if we take the word addiction now
it's actually just a pattern of behavior
now of course each pattern of behavior
will either
lead you to rewards or will lead you to
punishment
but
if you see it for what it is then you
understand a pattern of behavior can
only be changed if you replace it with
something else
and a lot of times people replace it
with something
worse you know it's like you don't want
to you don't want to change one person
for another poison
so in this sense it's like
you want to change that pattern of
behavior with different patterns of
behavior which those patterns of
behavior could be
self-improvement you know
maybe developing yourself
in your faith
you know in your deen
um and developing yourself financially
so you can support a wife because once
you do those two
you're completing or first part the
self-improvement
you're completing your 50
of your deen and then once you have the
financial aspect done and you get
married now you've completed the other
50 of your deen
you see what i'm saying so it's like
it's very simple it's just a matter of
like asking these questions and like
going deep deeper down into your your
psychology and figuring out
how you're working and how is everything
going on here
it's so amazing refreshing to see
someone who went through the journey
like you have
and now where you're at today
you know giving this advice you know
with the islamic touch in it
it's just so beautiful to see
so what was that because it's no secret
now at the end you ended up coming to
islam uh that complete and total
submission to the one and only creator
that happens in the earth the one that
jesus worshiped the one that noah
worship abraham that pure monotheism
accepting the last and final messenger
sent to mankind a simple message worship
one and only one god not his creation
and be morally upright that's islam you
live in islam alhamdulillah
what was it at the end that had you
finally
because you left it until the end
so what was it at the end when you went
to all of the different
things that are out there that had you
accept islam
so the thing that had me accepted 100
and stop putting it off
was the fact that uh
i was at my lowest point
you know i had um i had just gotten
surgery
um the whole culver thing was going on
so i wasn't really you know spending
time with other people i was by myself i
was in pain
i couldn't work out i couldn't move and
i'm a pretty physical individual i like
just like playing sports i like working
out i like training martial arts like
doing all these things always keeping
emotion that's how like mentally i would
keep saying
and once i had that stripped away from
me and then i had no
social interactions and
you know i kind of knew intuitively that
i didn't want to play video games and i
didn't want to like watch tv shows and
movies and all that stuff because i knew
i would just kind of use that as a
an escape
so once i was there just kind of sitting
at my lowest point depressed
i was like yeah i got to do something
and then the only thing that came to my
mind was like okay
last time i was in this position i did
dope detox
and i started to come
to the answers
you know
and i even spoke about this where the
first time i did doping detox i started
to feel the pull towards islam but i
didn't i didn't you know answer that i
didn't go to it
like i said i was scared of knowing the
truth 100
and um
this time like all i was thinking about
was just feeling better i didn't want to
feel depressed i just wanted to feel
better so i started doing the dopamine
detox and then i started saying feel
that same pool to islam
and for like
three days maybe
three days i'd say
i kept putting it off i was you know
what no like i'm doing this dopamine
detox i don't want to read i don't wanna
do anything i'm just gonna sit and
meditate and reflect and heal from
whatever it is that i gotta hear from
and then by the third day i was like you
know what
let me just read let me just read the
quran because
i have it
it's just reading it's holy text so it's
not like it's destroying this whole
doping detox process
and that's when i started reading it and
once i started reading about the rest of
history
so would you would you um the what
advice would you give read would you say
read the quran you've read every other
book joe rogan whoever else is out there
just read the quran a good
english translation or spanish or
whatever background you come from read
the quran start with that
uh
i want to say read the quran
but it's like with every person like
it's it's subject to individuality
exactly yeah so like someone reading the
crown might be a hundred percent for
them
and then for another person
it might be that self-reflection that
they need for another person it might
just be breaking out of their shell like
being more social talking to people more
so they can
[Music]
kind of open their mind because what
ends up happening is
we
close ourselves off and when we are
closed off
we close ourselves off to guidance
right and
like for whatever reason we close
ourselves off we need to figure out what
that reason is and start to kind of open
up from there but
i'd still say reading the quran is a big
a big piece of the puzzle here for sure
when did you at what point did you ask
this seems something it just seems like
something so simple
a lot of people they just don't do the
simple right they do the complicated and
the convoluted just asking the creator
the one who
created creation guide me like
you created me guide me like did you uh
end up doing that at one point asking
god the creator of the heavens and the
earth not jesus not muhammad but just
not the sun not the move none of these
things and create not the crystals not
the jinn not the spirits but just the
one who created everything yeah so it's
crazy that you can bring that up but
when i was christian
and i was with my ex-fiance
i remember i would
because i still had that new age
mentality so i was always constantly
like researching custom looking things
up and trying to like
piece the the pieces in my head and i
would always come to these like crazy
these crazy conclusions and i'd share
that with everyone because i thought it
was so crazy and and some people loved
it some people were like brothers that's
just too much
but i remember talking to my ex-fiance's
mom at the time
and i was like telling her all this
stuff and i was so passionate about it
because i was like making these uh
connections in my head and she shared
this thing with me
saying that like
it was talking about god and obviously
in the context they were probably you
know referring to jesus but
what was said in this little piece was
basically saying like
uh
man is always trying to understand
further like we're always trying to
basically like
the mind is always trying to
come up with this complex
answer
when it's like you you don't need to do
that it's it's very simple you just you
come to me and and the thing was like
you come to me you come into my presence
and
you will be
you will be at peace
and like when i read that i was like
wow like
this is too simple this is too simple
for me
and then like it never kind of it never
left i'll be honest it never left and i
i kind of started to
i kind of started to simplify things
over time
and like the more i simplified it
the more i kept asking like oh
this seems too complicated like
how can this be more simple how can
like what what's the what's the what's
the most simple way here and i kept
asking the question what's the most
simple way here
and
here i am bro in islam
alhamdulillah
so
that's amazing because shaitaan makes it
complicated right and seems like oh
there's so many religions uh they're all
teaching good they're all you know away
like spokes on the wheel but when you
look into the different religions you
know in all respect you know to the
people you're not trying to disparage on
any but you can see it one form or
another like you were talking about the
the way of life that the
you're the woman you're going to marry
you just saw a contradiction after
contradiction it didn't make sense too
much left interpretation you wanted
something straightforward clear simple
and in one way or another these man-made
religions are calling you to worship the
creation
confusion but when you come to islam
it's straightforward it's clear
it's like
i compare it like from darkness to light
yeah
yeah and you're living testimony to that
so with the people out there who have
all these prejudices
stereotypes
media manipulation has gotten to them
what do you say to people like that but
they have that deep void
right and they're stumbling in the dark
what do you like to tell someone like
that
i say look for the truth
for the answers like if you if you
sincerely want to know the answers
if you sincerely want to be at peace
if you sincerely want to live the best
life that you can live
look for the answers because they're
there
and the more sincere you become in your
search
the more you'll be guided and eventually
you'll you'll find what you're looking
for you see now we've got a few minutes
left for the muslims out there everyone
develops differently with their
spirituality we understand but now
alhamdulillah you're getting grounded
more and more into the deen but then
when you see people taking
things for granted have you seen some of
that
where now some of the basic stuff you
know hijab is not islam is a part of
islam the beard is not islam is part of
islam but then you just make that small
example with the other things like
prayer the bigger things you know and
now
simple things that can be
making your life less complicated but
you see a lot of muslims taking it for
granted and not implementing salah not
implementing the dean actually sometimes
being an obstacle for people like you
will come and say oh you don't have to
put the beer you don't have to wear
hijab you don't have to do this you
don't have to give up this that and the
other right have you seen some of this
and what's your response to that advice
for those who are also struggling in
that arena of confusion and they're
muslim
[Music]
the first thing i'd ask is like is that
bringing you peace
you know because
if they're thinking that way
it's probably because in the
where they're living their environment
what they are subject to
you know or you have muslims and they
live in the west
and no
like there's no women over here that are
really covering up
if anything they're trying to
wear as little as possible over here in
the west
so i was like you have that constantly
being bombarded
and if if the woman is
let's say that this muslim like she's
going on social media a lot
she's watching
tv shows and all that and then her
friends are also non-muslim and she's
going out into society and she's seeing
all these non-muslim women
do you not think that that's gonna
affect your psychology like we are a
product of our environment
so if the girl if the muslim is thinking
this way if she doesn't want to wear the
hijab and
she doesn't want to do these so-and-so
things like you got to ask yourself the
real question like is this bringing you
peace
is this
and if not then
why
you know and from there you
from this
i don't want to get too complex with it
but it's asking yourself a simple
question it's like is this bringing me
peace is it bringing me happiness and
why is it that i'm doing what i'm doing
people cannot catch up with you and the
other brothers the three muslims
uh tell us about that
yes where else people can hook up with
you to learn more
what's your story
uh if you guys just want to hear my
stuff and like the videos that i put out
over like self-improvement you can go to
my personal channel
which is my name but with an extra eight
extra eight
and then if if you want to get into the
real stuff the you know the spirituality
aspect
islam
uh philosophy all this beautiful stuff
that's where i have the uh the three
muslim channel i'm a part of that with
two other brothers
and we we try to put up as much content
as possible
try to keep it real
try to keep it raw and unfiltered
because
our main intention from the beginning
was
kind of just recording our conversations
that we were having
so that way other people can be a part
of that conversation you know yeah
you're not there physically with us
but you're a part of it and i feel like
that's something that we as uh
humans we're just kind of missing that
you know it's not very often that you
meet other people
who are on the same wave as you
you know so
we made these videos
with that intention
and we're just
we're trying to help that's it
and beautiful inshallah this can be a
benefit because we're not just trying to
tell stories we're trying to change
lives so your story has a lot of good
behind alhamdulillah and hopefully
people like mr joe rogan
and others like him and people who have
these preconceived notions just like you
did oh muslims are arabs or they're
oppressive and all this other nonsense
right all the media manipulation that's
happening in the world people can see
behind that you just gave them a taste
and if they're sincere and they want to
know the truth inshallah this can
inspire people to look
more further than this they've been seen
and uh thank you very much man it was
really nice uh talking with you
for having i mean i mean we're gonna
have to do it again we didn't we just
crashed the surface i got a lot i'd like
to talk to you more about inshallah we
can do that in the future
and thank you guys for tuning in another
amazing story with our brother haniel
uh go ahead and um
leave us uh the comments in the comments
below what you thought
any uh things you'd like us to talk to
him about in the future maybe on a
program we'll do with him inshallah i
really joined talking to the brother
subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification bell and we'll see you
next time here on the dean show until
then peace